okay let's go to our caller from the
five four zero area code who's calling
today from five four zero hi David I'm
William hey William what's going on the
reason I'm caught the reason I'm calling
today is been about subscriber and
listener a couple of years now
yeah and for the most part are very much
enjoy your programming but I think I and
others have tried to bring to your
attention there's new it's a religious a
group called the new independent
fundamental Baptist okay you're breaking
or thank you said that the group is
called the new independent
fundamentalist what about this Baptists
okay okay the NFIB in them their main
point of matter of fact they had a rally
on the weekend of the post
nightclub shooting down in Orlando okay
and basically what they're trying to do
is they're trying to rile up their
people to try to get the government to
not only make homosexual or
homosexuality illegal yeah to execute
homosexual homosexuals yeah there have
been with that idea around for a while
you know that it's not going anywhere I
mean there's not really a risk that
that's going to happen in the US and
yeah they're gonna have to ban gay
marriage before they go to killing the
gays so I just don't know that I've not
heard of the screwball look into them
but it doesn't sound like they have much
influence well the thing is that since
2006 they have grown to having over 40
churches across the country yeah and
they continue to grow and just recently
in Tennessee there was a
the pastor who was also a sheriff or
deputy sheriff in that count who was a
member of the NIF be okay who was
calling for the for the execution and
you just said that you would look look
into it and I guess that's why I called
because I know I in several other armed
people had I had gone on your subreddit
and I had also sent you an email in
regards to this okay and I said and I
hadn't heard anything okay I appreciate
that I mean just understand that you
know we get every day we get about 3,000
contacts from the audience across our
all of our different platforms so I
can't react or respond to everything
individually or cover everything but
I'll check into this group you're
talking about and I would appreciate
that very much
all right very good thank you so much
for the call great to hear from you
let's go to break sorry as always to
everybody I didn't get to but I am under
advise from the audience spending a
little more time with each caller will
see if people like that and we will take
calls again next week